I guess I'll start this Reflection by
posing the following question which is
what kind of person do we want to be who
do we want to be what qualities do we
want to emulate what kind of confidence
do we want to embody what kind of jazz
do we want to become
and
you know I'm reminded of uh of an
archetype that was analyzed in a video
essay by a YouTuber called like stories
of old and he spoke of a particular kind
of masculinity he spoke of a particular
kind of swagger he spoke of a particular
kind of embodiment a particular kind of
confidence a particular kind of way of
showing up in the world and he likened
this archetype to the Tyler Durden
character played by Brad Pitt in Fight
Club and he spoke of this character as
a compelling figure that
invites us into a kind of Trance there's
an entrancing quality to this Tyler
Durden archetype to the Bodhi character
in the film Point Break we all want to
be like Bodhi and the question is what
makes Bodhi so compelling what makes
Tyler Durden so compelling and in the
words of this YouTuber well that's the
infectiousness of the unconflicted man
apparently that's a term
I'm not sure who coined it but the
infectiousness of the unconflicted man
is a very real thing the unconflicted
man is the man who doesn't
believe nor doubt he knows the
infectiousness of the unconflicted man
comes from a kind of intuitive knowing a
cool swagger it's Paul Newman and Cool
Hand Luke the infectiousness of the
unconflicted man is a kind of
is a kind of archetype that points the
way to our inner Vitruvian man you know
it when you see it you have to go there
to know there you must become what you
behold and we are inspired by these
characters on screen by the Luminosity
that they seem to emanate by the Swagger
and way in which they show up in the
world and the question becomes then how
perhaps through a process of osmosis can
we absorb those qualities how do we
evoke those qualities how do we give
birth to those qualities within our
selves how do we assume the role
of the unconflicted man how do we become
the unconflicted man how do we learn to
emanate and and disclose and evoke in
others the infectiousness of the
unconflicted man and it is this question
it is this this challenge that I pose
myself
at this moment in my life the astounding
Frontier of the present moment as I lean
into the abyss as I as I leap into the
trust fall I take a leap of faith and
together we go be young men together
again you know this is my challenge in
this moment in my life this is my
invitation into myself this is my Bliss
[ __ ] crucifixion this is my goodness
you know this is to to finally assume
the Viewpoint assume the vantage point
to become to become the infectiousness
of the unconflicted man
and to gaze into the Horizon and to
stare into the sunset into Marvel at the
realization to to sit in the Gratitude
to to to
evoke the serenity
to not believe nor doubt but to know
but to know
but to know
[Music]